well another group of clark county
school district students returned to
campus today we're talking about cohort
b
they started in-person learning under
the hybrid instruction model
8 news now reporter kristen drummond is
live in the newsroom with how families
and students adjusted
kristen well denise roughly 20 000
students went in buildings for the first
time in nearly a year
they are the other half of the more than
40 000 pre-kindergarten to third grade
students
attending class in person this week
around the valley now cohort b follows
the same plan as cohort a
two days of in-person learning and three
days of distance education
except cohort b comes on campuses
thursday and friday
instead of monday and tuesday now
various families and ccsd
staff say the overall transition is
going well like it did earlier this week
the schedule is a minor adjustment but
some parents tell me their children
seem to be excited to return she was so
happy
a little nervous but we got to the bus
stop and at least one friend was there
so she felt better they both got on the
bus together
now here are the latest cohort numbers
from ccsd
nearly 22 000 in cohort a roughly 20 000
in cohort b
and more than 50 000 in cohort c which
is full-time distance education
the data from ccsd shows a couple
hundred students are no longer doing
full-time distance education
it's likely those children switch to
hybrid learning this week since
both cohorts a and b gained more
students according to the numbers now
that's a trend the district does expect
to continue
happening the rest of this school year
elementary schools are starting to also
focus on preparing for
in-person instruction five days a week
that starts on april 6
for pre-kindergarten to fifth grade
full-time distance education remains an
option though for families
who prefer remote learning reporting
live in the newsroom kristin drummond
8 news now kristin thank you for that